quarantine confession Luke Wilson I'm  gonna be honest with you for the first  few weeks of this pandemic I thought we  were supposed to wear the masks over our  ears coefficient sometimes people mix me  up with the other Wilson the volleyball  from castaway fish originally idiocracy  it's not supposed to be a documentary  quadfession sometimes I wanted post  meets those hi well I just want to look  into the eyes of another human for the  sea they are I'll see you tomorrow  going fishing sometimes when I watch old  movies have been in and my scenes gone I  lean in and whisper to the screen nice  job  quarantine quadfession